ravi de vous retrouver pour le journal
de l'afrique soyez les bienvenus sur
france 24 à la une ce soir raïla odinga
qui conteste les résultats de la
présidentielle kenyane le candidat
malheureux elle les qualifient de
parodie le vice-président sortant
williams routot a été déclaré vainqueur
avec plus de 50% des voix pour 48,85 %
pour heil odinga la correspondance à
l'aéroport dans ce journal la courte
visite de macky sall au tchad le
président sénégalais président en
exercice de l'union africaine s'est
rendu à n'djamena il a rencontré le
président du conseil militaire de la
transition matin idrissi délit au coeur
des discussions la transition en cours
dans le pays les détails à suivre
enfin on va s'intéresser ce soir à la
dépigmentation volontaire un phénomène
qui a toujours inquiétés et qui s'étend
elle les méthodes et les produits sont
dangereux mais la prévention n'est pas à
la hauteur du diktat de l'esthétique on
en parle à la fin de ce journal avec
notre invité alors verneuil hauteur de
décolorer
c'était sa cinquième présidentielle à
raila odinga à 77 ans cette figure de
l'opposition à kényane a encore échoué
c'est son rival le vice-président
sortant williams goutta qui a été
déclaré vainqueur par la commission
électorale avec plus de 50% des
suffrages raïla odinga pour tests les
résultats écouter
ce que nous avons vu hier est une
parodie un mépris flagrant de la
constitution et des lois du kenya de la
part du président chez bugatti d'une
minorité de commissaires de la
commission électorale a et b c comme et
shannon
voilà raïla odinga qui a promis un
recours devant la cour suprême
il ne compte pas baisser les bras comme
nous l'expliquent notre correspondant à
nairobi bastien revenu
après des violences qui ont succédé à
l'annoncé des résultats la ville de
kisumu à l'ouest du pays et les
bidonvilles de kibera et de matar est
ici à nairobi des bastions de raila
odinga se sont réveillées dans le calme
ce mardi matin un calme qui a perduré
toute la journée leur population
attendez d'entendre raïla odinga de
savoir quelle serait la marche à suivre
pour la suite le leader du mouvement à
imola au mode à s'est exprimé ils
contestent toujours les résultats mais
il appelle à la paix et je peux vous
dire que dans le pays bien la population
est partagée entre ses soutiens et ses
opposants écoutez les
odinga a rejeté les résultats et selon
nous qui avons passé un peu de temps à
l'école les chiffres annoncés n'étaient
pas correctes le président de la
commission électorale a subi des
pressions ce n'est pas possible qu'après
avoir travaillé ensemble son équipe le
désavouent comme ça à la dernière minute
nawa quitter poitiers
ttacc à quinn dianna il ya tout le monde
peut faire vérifier les chiffres sur le
site de la commission électorale je
pense que si rails la roja les résultats
c'est parce qu'il n'est pas content
l'année mais nous nous sommes sur le
vélo d'inga dispose de sept jours pour
déposer sa requête devant la cour
suprême et cette dernière disposera
ensuite de 14 jours pour rendre son
verdict le parti asie new lao modja
devra rendre un dossier extrêmement
complet détaillant et justifiant toutes
les accusations de fraudes et
d'irrégularités contre la commission
électorale
c'est ce qu'avait déjà fait raila odinga
en 2017 à l'époque il accusait déjà la
commission électorale d'irrégularités et
la cour suprême lui avait donné raison
pour une première en afrique
subsaharienne elle avait annulé le
scrutin présidentiel alors nul doute que
en attendant le verdict de cette cour
est bien tous les kenyans seront rivés
sur l'actualité politique du pays pour
savoir quelle sera la suite de cette
élection présidentielle
le ballet diplomatique au tchad à trois
jours de l'ouverture du dialogue
nationale macky sall le président
sénégalais président en exercice de
l'union africaine a effectué un court
séjour n'djamena où il s'est entretenu
avec le président du conseil militaire
de la transition mahamat idriss deby au
coeur des discussions la transition les
précisions de notre correspondant
mamadou dig t by
le présent macky sall a appelé toutes
les parties prenantes tchadienne à
participer au dialogue dans l'intérêt
supérieur de leur pays un appel lancé
car ici à n'djamena une partie de
l'opposition refuse toujours d'y
participer comme le parti des
transformateurs ou le mouvement citoyen
ouakid tama le fac l'un des plus
importants groupes rebelles ne sera pas
de la partie non plus tous dénoncent un
dialogue joué d'avancé le précité
présent macky sall ne s'est pas prononcé
sur la durée là sans tout en saluant le
processus politique en cours pour rappel
l'union africaine avait exigé que la
transition tchadienne sa chef en
dix-huit mois débouchant sur des
élections un délais impossibles à
respecter selon une partie de
l'opposition qui accuse le cnt de
vouloir jouer les prolongations autre
visite diplomatique celle du commissaire
paix et sécurité de l'union africaine
dans le col et adoré y est objectif
rencontrer les acteurs politiques et la
société civile le prison de la
commission de l'union africaine moussa
faki mahamat je trouve également en
djamena où il doit prendre part à
l'ouverture du dialogue national
inclusif censées se tenir le samedi 20
août
ce triste anniversaire en afrique du sud
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées ce mardi americana dix ans
jour pour jour après le massacre de
mineurs grévistes dans la pire fusillade
policière depuis la fin de l'apartheid
sophie lamothe
c'est ici sur cette colline que les 34
manifestants étaient tués il ya dix ans
des milliers de personnes retournent sur
les lieux du crime pour commémorer le
massacre de marie cana
[Musique]
dix ans se sont écoulés nous sommes
toujours debout sur cette colline
exigent des réponses par rapport à ceux
qui ont tué les manifestants
alors qu'ils demandaient simplement de
l'argent à leur employeur
ils réclamaient un meilleur salaire
lorsque les forces de police ont tiré
sur la foule sous les yeux des caméras
du monde entier le bilan est lourd 34
morts et 78 blessés dix personnes ont
également été tuées dans la semaine
précédent le massacre
une enquête officielle pointe le doigt
vers les violences policières certains
ont même été abattu lorsqu'il fuyait ou
tentaient de se rendre à la police
[Musique]
dix ans plus tard personne n'a été
inculpé pour les activistes il n'y a pas
de justice il tente de garder vivante la
mémoire de ce tragique incident le mari
cana musicale reconstitue les événements
du 16 août 2012
nous avons cet incident le coup des gens
font tuer des gens sont trop de thunes
il est donc important d'ouvrir la
conversation libérer la parole pour que
les gens puissent en parler pour moi
c'est un travail important de
commémorations
la comédie musicale rappel de nombreux
massacres perpétrés contre les
communautés noires en afrique du sud
comme le massacre de sharpeville où 69
personnes ont été tuées par la police en
1960 il militait contre le régime de
l'apartheid
[Musique]
on en vient à ce litige entre
l'équipementier français le coq sportif
et la fédération camerounaise de
football la fécafoot a signé un contrat
de trois ans avec l'équipementier
américain world skies alors que son
contrat avec le coq sportif est en cours
jusqu'à 2023 la marque française compte
bien obtenir réparation devant la
justice les détails de notre
correspondant à yaoundé marcel a
beaucoup
la nouvelle a fait l'effet d'une bombe
ici au cameroun c'est donc la société
américaine one au spot qui va habiller
les lions indomptables durant les trois
prochaines années annonce faite par la
fédération camerounaise de football dans
un communiqué la fécafoot qui sans plus
de détails parle du contrat le plus
juteux de l'histoire de l'équipe
nationale de football du cameroun le 6
le choix de l'américain wallace porte
assure près la réaction de
l'équipementier français le corps
sportifs dont le contrat qui courait
jusqu'en 2023 a été unilatéralement
rompu par la fédération comme les au
football ne s'est pas fait attendre le
coq sportif qui annonce avoir assigné la
fécafoot afin de faire respecter le
contrat liant les deux parties et la
reconnaissance de ces droits un nouvel
épisode judiciaire qui s'annonce donc
pour samuel eto'o fils le président de
la fédération anglaise de football et
ses équipes qui viennent d'être
condamnés à verser près d'un milliard de
francs cfa un peu plus d'un million cinq
cent vingt mille euros à antonio conte
ccao l'ex sélectionneur des lions
indomptables le licencié abusivement
selon lui et qui a obtenu gain de cause
devant la justice une saga judiciaire
entre la fédération camerounaise de
football et au coq sportif qui tient les
camerounais en haleine sur fond de
bataille entre samuel eto'o fils et
yannick noah deux des plus grandes stars
que le cameroun a connu
et ce soir on va vous parler de la
dépigmentation volontaire un phénomène
qui existe sur tous les continents et
qui fait des dégâts en afrique les
méthodes utilisées sont dangereuses mais
le matraquage publicitaire le diktat de
l'esthétique l'emportent souvent sur la
peur des effets secondaires pour en
parler nous recevons ce soir un or
verneuil hauteur de décolorer qui
revient justement sur ce phénomène merci
beaucoup anne laure verneuil d'être avec
nous merci pour l'invitation alors la
première question qu'on a envie de vous
poser c'est pourquoi vous avez décidé de
faire ce livre qui est complet cet
ouvrage qui parle justement cette
dépigmentation volontaire ses effets
secondaires les méthodes et c'est
pourquoi
alors ma mère est noir elle a toujours
été très fier de sa couleur de peau donc
j'ai grandi avec ce modèle de beauté et
de fait monter et par adam parallèlement
à ça c'est vrai que j'étais confronté à
ces jeunes finalement pendant mes
vacances presque chaque année en haïti à
une différence de traitement du fait de
ma couleur de peau plus claire et l
époque déjà sam avait heurté interpellé
et quand j'ai appris l'existence de
produits pour pour s'éclaircir la peau
j'ai eu envie d'en faire le sujet
d'étude de mes recherches universitaires
et par la suite de transposer en fait
ces recherches se recherchent en un
livre un ouvrage tout public j'habite
maintenant au sénégal et je peux
constater au quotidien les ravages de
cette pratique donc ça m'a d'autant plus
donné envie de finaliser ce projet parce
que comme l'avait dit non c'est un
phénomène qui est massif présent
finalement partout et le but de ce livre
c'est d'offrir un panorama est surtout
d'informer de conscientiser et de
dissuader et on apprend beaucoup de
choses dans cet ouvrage
vous justement dans cet ouvrage vous
vous décortiquer ce fléau et vous
commencez par les motivations qui
poussent ces jeunes à opter pour ces
crèmes ou ses produits qui dépigmentent
la peau oui tout à fait alors il peut
avoir diverses motivations qui avant
dépendre d'un individu à l'autre mais on
retrouve souvent l'idée de plaire donc
vouloir plaire se rapprocher finalement
de ce qui est valorisé esthétiquement
notamment à travers les médias ou au
final on retrouve
une des représentations positive surtout
autour des carnations claire et une
marginalisation des peaux les plus
foncés
il ya aussi une volonté de se soustraire
à des discriminations parce que il ya
tout un background historique de
dévalorisation des carnations foncé on
doit à la colonisation mais aujourd'hui
encore en 2022 que l'on soit en haïti ou
au brésil en inde en france avoir une
peau foncée c'est être davantage soumis
à des discriminations donc ça peut être
encore une motivation il y en a d'autres
alors il y a aujourd'hui pléthore de
méthode est d'ailleurs le marché des
produits éclaircissants rapporte des
sommes colossales quelles sont ses
méthodes et ses produits on en connaît
on en connaît quelques-uns mais il y en
a de nombreux qu'on ne connaît pas
souvent alors il y en a beaucoup ça va
de l'utilisation de patches qu'on va se
coller sur la peau un peu comme les
patchs anti-tabac à des personnes qui
vont jusqu'à s'immerger dans des bains
d'eau de javel et entre ces deux
extrêmes on a des pilules de glu tation
on a des injections de corticoïdes on a
un nombre incalculable de produits
cosmétiques dépigmentant avec des
substances comme de l'hydroquinone du
mercure etc etc produits d'ailleurs se
vendent souvent comme étant des soins
pour la peau qui embellissent en mettant
en avant des extraits naturels comme de
la corde de la carotte du citron de la
vitamine c ce qui induit en fait le
consommateur en erreur parce que
les homes est en général la présence ou
la quantité de substances nocives pour
la santé
et ça et ça c'est gravissime alors
justement quels sont les risques de ces
produits qu'on présente comme des
produits de beauté
inoffensif il y en a énormément la liste
est longue ça va du concert au nécrose à
l'insuffisance rénale la perte de la vue
le diabète la cne les vergetures une
difficulté voire une impossibilité à la
cicatrisation avec un danger réel de
morts finalement pour les femmes
enceintes par exemple qui accoucha par
césarienne il ya une mise en danger
aussi du foetus parce qu'elle est femme
enceinte qui continue de pratiquer donc
il ya un risque de retard de croissance
voire de dégâts cérébraux voilà la liste
est longue et il ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de méthode des
pigments tente qu'ils ne soient qu il
soit son risque en fait pour la santé
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
arrêter ce phénomène il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire dans le livre je propose
des pistes d'action on peut par exemple
encadrer plus durement à les produits
dépigmentants disponible sur le marché
est légal
il faut aussi homogénéiser les lois a
lâché l'international parce que
finalement ce n'est pas normal que des
produits soient fabriqués dans l'union
européenne en suisse est interdit à la
vente dans ces pays parce que jugés
dangereux pour la santé des
consommateurs et se retrouvent en vente
dans plein d'autres pays et ailleurs
dans le monde donc il faut une
homogénéisation de ces lois il faut des
lois aussi plus dur certains pays comme
le rwanda par exemple on interdit
totalement à la vente de ses produits
malheureusement on en trouve encore
memoranda sur le marché illicite
à une autre initiative aussi ce serait
de sensibiliser la jeunesse en
instaurant par exemple une journée
sensibilisation dans les écoles avec des
fascicule pédagogique et c'est alors
très rapidement deux mots est ce que
vous avez un message justement aux
jeunes qui nous regardent et qui ont qui
ont recours très rapidement oui alors il
n'y a pas de méthode sans risque pour se
dépigmenter c'est les ai faits sont
extrêmement graves pour la santé si j'ai
un message à faire passer c'est que pour
que cette problématique soit prise en
charge par l'organisation mondiale de la
santé il faut que les demandes viennent
des états membres donc je sais qu'il ya
des comités qui vont se dérouler
prochainement la semaine prochaine à
lomé au togo donc fait la demande pour
que le mail oms puisse s'emparer de ses
premiers tickets agir à la fois large et
le message est passé merci beaucoup anne
laure verneuil vous êtes auteur de
décolorer c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]